special surprise where a cross-country
road trip is an atom award today
I'll am just doing this I'm gonna sneak
out what kind of employee yeah happy
painting today have you thought about
these pants for some no employee
business over do you eat any unusual
snacks when you're watching a movie you
know what movie people we're running
panzon do it like a press check
absolutely Chariots of Fire remember
that serious bomb pop call yourself
cheese in one of these dishes you roll
off watch one of your favorite academy
award nominated movies we're with the
Academy Awards and you aren't I swear to
God we're downstairs we have an Oscar
you can post the real-life Oscar and
right now you saw it right here right
now our three-week cross-country road
trip with an academy award has been
amazing every city we go to people are
just so nice and so excited to meet
Oscar touching it and feeling it I feel
a connection of with those people who
inspired and the Oscar goes to want to
thank everybody for all your support
thank you so much of course thanks
sprint for having the Oscar stop here at
campus like to thank my mom and all my
fans you inspire me like to thank mr.
Tyrone and miss Monica all the Boys and
Girls Clubs my school am I fake my kids
everyone wears on me through the years
what do you want to tell a miracle thank
you
it's all happening sunday the Oscars